oh
non
roland garros les pensées en bonne forme
lecomte qualifiée noise toujours en
course résumé de la journée direct sur
le court central dans quelques minutes
l'arrêtant est vrai qu'une double
attaque d'oslo palestiniens fake tel
aviv il s'apprête à commettre des
attentats cap commandes du commandant
c'était eux les autres sont arrêtés
enfin l'ancien directeur de cabinet de
pierre bérégovoy sur le point d'être
inculpé dans la sphère du délit d'initié
sur la société générale jean charles
naouri est l'une des cinq personnes dans
le parti a demandé l'inculpation
bonsoir suspense et spectacle garanti
avec yannick noah à roland garros le
français était mené 6 5 dans le deuxième
set à 19h07
à l'issue de la première partie du 19/20
à qu'il réussit à égaliser ou à
l'emporter dominique champeau là où il
n'a pas égalisé à la fois en santé 9 lui
il a tout simplement faire vu la
deuxième manche 5 5 en abandonnant son
service à son adversaire le canadien
andrew schnyder met meilhan nouvelle
dans la troisième manche il mène
actuellement 3,1 et schnyder qui est au
service mène 3 0 donc yannick noah a
fait le break en début de troisième set
et c'est très important pour lui car
psychologiquement il se doit maintenant
que marquer des points de remettre un
petit peu la main sur la partie
dominique dominique on vous entend ou ne
vous voit pas on a plus l'image de
roland garros il ya un incident
technique
on vous rappellera de toute façon au
cours de ce journal ce match joué par
eric toit sera en quelque sorte le fil
conducteur du 19/20 j'espère qu'on
retrouvera l'image on la retrouve sur
l'écran de contrôle voilà donc voilà
andrew ladd joueur qui répond maintenant
aux attaques de yannick doha je garde
l'antenne comme vous aimeriez conserver
30 selon nous voient la fin de ce jeu
peut-être voilà 40-15 glider dispose
donc de deux balles pour revenir à 3
jeux à 2 mais comme je voulais dit il a
un service de retard maintenant dans ce
troisième set service qu'il a concédé
tout à l'heure à yannick nord
3 tous les tons que dans la troisième
manche sur service de yannick là à
suivre et une belle option pour le
français dans ce troisième jules merci
dominique et match à suivre tout au long
de ce 19 ainsi le match continue après
20 heures
l'a3 le diffuseur direct accrochage
meurtrier entre palestiniens et
israéliens sur une plage près de tel
aviv de commandos palestiniens ont été
ont tenté de débarquer mais ils ont été
surpris par l'armée israélienne quatre
d'entre eux ont été tués les autres ont
été capturés
joël hasard resserré en mer par les
hélicoptères israéliens les canaux
zodiac des deux commandos palestiniens
ont été interceptés au nord et au sud de
tel-aviv
l'un d accostage sur la plage de nice à
nîmes a ouvert le feu en direction des
soldats isréliens mêlant 4 fedayin a
battu l'autre n'aura pas le temps de
débarquer sur la plage de gâchis il sera
aussitôt capturer les commandos
palestiniens et leurs canots
pneumatiques ont été largués en haute
mer par un navire en provenance de libye
c'est ce qu'indiquent les autorités
militaires israéliennes qui ont détecté
l'opération dès son lancement pour
l'armée isralienne cette tentative
d'attaqué signé front de libération de
la palestine dabul abbas accusation
grave si elle se confirme aboul abass
qui fut le commanditaire du détournement
de la qu'il est là oro est en effet au
sein de l'ump l'un des responsables de
la lutte armée
reste à connaître l'intention réelle des
commandos objectif civil ou militaire
les autorités israéliennes ont affirmé
que les fedayin équipés de fusils
mitrailleurs et de grenades s'apprêtait
à commettre un massacre sur les plages
bondées de monde
ils étaient munis de photos précises du
littoral et pour avis pas se faire le
porte parole de cette famille ils ne
voulaient qu'une chose tuer le maximum
de gens dans le contexte actuel du
regain de violence ces dernières
opérations risquent de creuser davantage
le fossé entre israéliens et
palestiniens
elle pourrait signifier le retour à
l'escala dans la lutte armée de l'olp et
en l'absence de toute solution négociée
la roumanie la turquie la yougoslavie et
l'urss secoué ce midi par plusieurs
secousses telluriques l'épicentre du
tremblement de terre se trouvait dans
les carpates près de brasov et c'est en
roumanie qu'il a été
meurtrier le dernier bilan officiel fait
état de sept morts et 122 blessés
christian baise
environ 7 degrés sur l'échelle ouverte
de richter le séisme a été ressenti dans
plusieurs pays de l'est de la
yougoslavie jusqu'à moscou mais c'est en
roumanie mme se trouvait dans l'est du
pays
l'épicentre de la secousse que le
phénomène a été le plus violent ainsi à
bucarest deux personnes ont été tuées
par l'effondrement de bâtiments de
nombreux incendies se sont immédiatement
déclaré dans la capitale mais aussi dans
l'est et le centre du pays la police a
lancé un appel au calme à la population
paniquée la roumanie a déjà connu
plusieurs tremblements de terre dans
ceux de 77 et 86 beaucoup plus violent
que celui d'aujourd'hui
selon l'institut de physique du globe de
strasbourg qui a enregistré le phénomène
il existe un ni de tremblement de terre
dans cette région à une profondeur de
100 à 250 km
compte tenu de cette profondeur
importante l'institut ajoute que le
phénomène bien connu de répliques du
séisme qui intervient dans les heures ou
les jours qui suivent la première
secousse sera de faible intensité
et puis on vient de l'apprendre un
séisme a eu lieu la nuit dernière dans
le nord ouest du pérou le bilan est très
lourd au moins 38 morts ils ne se
quittent plus bush et gorbatchev vont se
revoir demain aux états unis mais depuis
leur dernière rencontre la position de
gorbatchev s'est singulièrement
affaiblie
le numéro un soviétique a
considérablement durci sa position sur
la question allemande l'allemagne qui
sera donc au centre des discussions
entre les deux chefs d'état sur ce point
comme sur d'autres
george bush reconnaît que les entretiens
seront âpres et difficiles vigiles du
jonchay ce week end george bush avait
beau jouer les père tranquille club de
golf à la main il reconnaissait que
faire changer d'avis le chef du kremlin
sur l'allemagne serait pour lui une rude
tâche
au cours de ce sommet mihai barbade chef
tout affaibli qu'il est par ses
multiples difficultés chez lui et peut
être même pour cette raison n'accepte
pas une allemagne tout entière dans
l'otan il a répété avec force vendredi
dernier en recevant françois mitterrand
à moscou menaçant même de prendre la
détente en europe en otage si les
occidentaux persistaient dans leur
entreprise
un tir de semonce qui a été pris au
sérieux à la maison blanche où on est
conscient du dilemme que pose à moscou
le statut militaire futur de l'allemagne
après les bouleversements intervenus au
centre de l'europe
l'urss re tout d'être rejetés vers
l'asie alors qu'un pôle atlantique
agrégerait ou éventrés les anciens
satellites dans le marchandage tous
azimuts qui s'annonce
george bush n'a pas l'intention
d'exploiter les malheurs du numéro un
soviétique il l'a redit hier mais il ne
fera pas de cadeaux non plus depuis leur
dernière rencontre à malte en décembre
beaucoup de choses ont changé
gorbatchev a perdu de son lustre au
point les américains pour cause de
lituanie le président américain lui
rappellera d'autre part que les
américains ont fait une concession
majeure au début de ce mois à bruxelles
en renonçant à leurs projets de
modernisation des missiles nucléaires de
courte portée basée en rfa autrement dit
c'est leur disparition à terme à ce jour
où washington l'a reçu en échange aucune
contrepartie dissensions sur l'allemagne
ne compromettent pas pour autant la
qualité des relations entre gorbatchev
et l'occident qui veulent aider dans sa
politique de réformes et qu'il illustre
en créant la berd la banque européenne
de reconstruction et de développement
mission de cette banque présidée par
jacques attali soutenir économiquement
l'union soviétique
marie-hélène tichot 40 pays la
commission de bruxelles et la banque
européenne d'investissement sont les
actionnaires de la banque européenne
pour la reconstruction et le
développement de leur violence
son capital s'élève à 70 milliards de
francs son objectif faire accéder les
pays de l'est à l'économie de marché
la berd veut concourir à la formation
participer aux privatisations et prendre
des participations minoritaires dans le
capital des entreprises
elle prêtera son argent 60% secteur
privé 40% en public son critère de choix
et potentiel de rentabilité des projets
cette institution est à la fois une très
grande banque qui sera dirigé par les
plus grands professionnels bancaire que
l'on pourra trouver sans aucune autre
exigence que leur plus haut niveau
professionnel mais qui est aussi au delà
de cela une institution ayant une forte
dimension politique à la fois je le
disais tout à l'heure
parce qu'elle est la première
institution rassemblant tous les pays
européens avec d'autres pour constituer
un ensemble capable de créer une vision
commune de toute l'europe mais aussi
peut-être surtout parce que je la pense
comme une institution de la paix et au
service de la paix la berd devrait
commencer à prêter de l'argent aux pays
de l'est en mars prochain
j'évoquais tout à l'heure les
difficultés de mikhaël gorbatchev et
vienne sont accrus avec la déclaration
que vient de faire boris elstine son
principal rival qui vient d'être élu
président de la fédération de russie la
russie vient il de dire d'oeuvre a
proclamé sa souveraineté d'ici cent
jours retour en france avec un
rebondissement dans la sphère de la
société générale et du délit d'initié
qui avait d'ailleurs échoué
j'en sors le nahouri l'ancien directeur
de cabinet de pierre bérégovoy devraient
être inculpés très prochainement le
parquet vient en effet de demander son
inculpation et celles de quatre autres
personnes albert ripamonti le retour de
balancier échaudés par les lois d'un
mystique ils ont dû appliquer à
contrecoeur les juges ne se rendront pas
complice d'un enterrement de première
classe dans la sphère de la société
générale
ce dossier remonte à 1988 lorsque
georges pébereau le pdg de mars aux
investissements lançant raid sur la
générale il dispose très certainement de
l'appui de pierre bérégovoy
l'opération consistant à briser le noyau
dur mis en place par edouard balladur au
moment de la privatisation
mais en février 89 la cob la commission
des opérations de bourse révèle que
plusieurs personnes ont bénéficié d'un
tuyau pour acheter des actions à prix
intéressants et s'enrichir
parmi elles jean charles naouri il
aurait réalisé une plus value de 340
mille francs c'est peu comparativement à
d'autres mais naouri est une pièce
sensible il fut directeur de cabinet de
pierre bérégovoy le parquet aujourd'hui
fait la même analyse que la coop
puisqu'il requiert l'inculpation de
naouri pour un délit d'initié
quatre autres personnes sont dans le
collimateur dont geneviève dalle la
femme de françois dalle l'ancien pdg de
l'oréal et l'on repart pour roland
garros sur le troisième set est
largement entamée yannick noah menthe il
toujours dominique champeau
absolument il mène toujours 4 jeux à 3
le tableau du central mais témoins 4
jeux à 3 service à suivre
et depuis le début de cette 3e manche et
bien son service a donné toutes
garanties
il a remporté le précédent en blanc
c'est à dire sans laisser le moindre
point à son adversaire andrew schnyder
un petit peu moins fringant que dans les
deux sets précédents lui est obligé de
se battre pour gagner chaque point sur
chacun de ses engagements yannick noah
lui répond du tac au tac et même si ce
n'est pas encore le rendra que l'on a
connue ici en 1983 eh bien on le sent
déjà plus présents plus mobiles peu avec
eux jouent avec davantage de conviction
il a fait des volets super digne donc du
grand bras il recommence à bien servir
et il est important pour lui de jouer
pour mieux jouer
on suit cette deuxième balle le mandat
ni merci
15h02 que 30,0 maintenant voyez que les
services reviennent moins fréquemment
match lens-caen
schnyder commence à accuser un petit peu
le coup nous jouons depuis 1h56 et on
retrouvera pour la fin de ce troisième
set dominique nous serons là merci elise
il est chef d'entreprise mais il est
aussi le maire d'une petite commune de
haute savoie et ce soir il est derrière
les verrous depuis plusieurs semaines le
maire de montclar emploi y est en effet
une dizaine de travailleurs clandestins
il a été inculpé et écroué reportage à
grenoble christian chevalier 7 mars un
maçon marocain mohamed hassad qui a fait
embaucher une quarantaine de mâts sont
sûrs par jean pierre pothin est inculpé
pour travail clandestin et marchandages
de main d'oeuvre
début mai un intermédiaire qui a fait
connaître le convoyeur aux chefs
d'entreprise est inculpé à son tour
mardi 29 mai c'est jean pierre pothin
qui est inculpé pour avoir eu recours à
des travailleurs clandestins et pour
marchandage de main d'oeuvre
l' enquête a permis d'établir que toutes
les charges sociales de ces travailleurs
n'était pas versée
le profit tiré de ces malversations a
été estimé à 350 milles francs nous
n'avons certainement pas retirer de
bénéfice
ils ont supérieurs à ce que voudrait
retirer avec nos propres aux ouvriers
pour la bonne raison que les employés de
monsieur asap était quelquefois mieux
rémunérés que le nôtre l'inculpation de
jean pierre pothin a surpris hannong la
roue le chef d'entreprise et maire du
village depuis 1983 une inculpation qui
n'a pas été assortie d'un dépôt de
caution mais d'une incarcération
ainsi en a décidé madame philippe juge
chargé du dossier au tribunal d'annecy
reste à savoir à qui ont profité ces
malversations au pot wire qui s'est déjà
fait connaître dans le sud de la france
pour de tels actes ou aux chefs
d'entreprise l'ex-otage jacqueline
valente condamné pour non représentation
d'enfant à six mois d'emprisonnement
dont deux ferme
les raisons de cette condamnation avec
pascal justice l'ex otage du cil coir
at-elle en prison le tribunal l'a
condamné à deux mois d'emprisonnement
ferme et quatre avec sursis
mais c'est libre que jacqueline valente
a quitté le prétoire charges retenues
non présentation d'enfant les faits
remontent à 85
à cette époque son ex mari pascal betty
y avait la garde de leurs deux filles et
jacqueline des droits de visite
mais au retour des vacances au lieu de
ramener les deux fillettes à leur père
jacques une valente décide de les
emmener en croisière
la traversée se soldera par leur
enlèvement marie laure et virginie
libéré en décembre 88 seront vendus à
leur père pour lui la peine est
justifiée car il s'agit d'un véritable
enlèvement
pour ce qui est de sa peine ils ont
quand même fait des faux papiers
j'emmène tout comme édité
donc
on nous dit cissé
ce même s'il y avait eu plus le
procureur avait demandé une peine
d'emprisonnement d'un mois avec sursis
mais le tribunal irrité par le mutisme
de l'accusé a été beaucoup plus sévère
la défense peut faire appel et demandé
une expertise psychiatrique pour lui
éviter de purger sa peine
elle peut aussi bénéficier de la loi
d'amnistié de 1988 applicables à ce type
de jugement
les 882 jour que jacqueline valente a
passés en captivité au proche orient
pourraient alors motiver une telle
procédure tout de suite en bref les
autres faits marquants de l'actualité en
france nathalie darrigrand
de 1,31 g d'alcool dans le sang le
chauffeur de ce poids lourd a percuté un
autocar scolaire sur la nationale 4 pré
d'auge et milliers en meurthe et moselle
dix enfants ont été légèrement blessés
leur conducteur lui est toujours à
l'hôpital
on ne connaît toujours pas les causes
exactes de la série d'intoxications
alimentaires à belfort
seule certitude les quarante victimes
déjà connus ont toutes mangé des gâteaux
d'une pâtisserie industrielle de la
ville les analyses effectuées sur les
malades ont décelé de la salmonellose
manifestation à saint-herblain cet après
midi malgré la remise en détention hier
des trois skinheads responsable de la
profanation du cimetière de la ville
les organisateurs qui réclamaient leur
retour en prison ont tenu à défiler pour
protester contre le racisme et
l'antisémitisme en général opérations
aux prisons morte dans la centrale de
moulins dans l'allier
depuis lundi les détenus refusent de se
rendre aux ateliers à la cantine et la
promenade certains repoussent leur
plateau repas certains seulement car ce
soir le mouvement serait pratiquement
terminé objectif protester contre les
conditions de détention
pas de jugement avant le 27 juin pour
les quatre dirigeants de la communauté
du fréchou le procureur de la république
a même demandé leur relaxe selon lui il
n'y a eu ni usage de fausse qualité ni
manoeuvres frauduleuses
hier pourtant à représentants de
l'église catholique a qualifié la
fraternité notre dame du fréchou de
secteur grandir sans tabac c'est le
slogan de la 3e journée contre le tabac
qui aura lieu demain dans le monde
entier mais ça tombe bien puisque selon
un sondage les jeunes fument beaucoup
moins le nombre des fumeurs entre 12 et
18 ans en effet baissé de 7 % en 10 ans
reste pourtant un million et demi de
jeunes intoxiqués
sachez encore pâle avant de jeter votre
paquet de cigarettes que le tabac tue
une personne toutes les 13 secondes
c'est que juste que je ne jetterai
j'espère vite les 13 secondes dans le
monde
reportage morad aït habbouche et joseph
tual
12h30 à la sortie du lycée camille sée à
paris après une matinée de travail
premier réflexe la clope pratiquement
sur toutes les lèvres
un geste multipliées tout au long de la
journée dix vingt trente fois souvent
plus un constat de l'organisation
mondiale de la santé
les jeunes commencent de plus en plus
tôt ensuite difficile de s'en passer
mais tout simple comme et contre
commerce conformément au combien par
jour 1 2 mais un paquet pourtant la
consommation chez les 12 18 ans diminue
et 7 % en dix ans ne fumait pas ne
fumait plus une cigarette écrasé un peu
de liberté gagnée et cetera et cetera
autant de campagnes qui ont favorisé
cette baisse mais il reste un million et
demi de jeunes qui fument encore
inconscients des dangers à long terme
quand on regarde les dégâts sur la santé
ils sont quand même très important et 60
mille morts par an alors c'est assez
curieux comme on banalise on arrive à
banaliser soixante mille morts par an
c'est énorme
alors donc c'est pas c'est vrai que
c'est pas très dynamisant de dire les
dangers pour les je ne sais pas ça qu'il
est douce mais c'est une forme de piège
quand même qu'ils aient c'est une
dépendance qui est qui et pas
valorisante plus malins certains ont
arrêté de fumer
désormais grâce aux emballages ils
s'enrichissent il avait koala dans la
main j'ai un paquet ciel parce que je
garde mes papiers
or actuellement on à 1700 francs alors
que les femmes battues
avant de retrouver à roland garros en
direct dominique champeau yannick noah
qui tentent de gagner le troisième set
revenons sur la journée avec caroline
since et jean philippe guillem journée
marquée par la défaite du français
florian faso à thiès nos coffres mais
par les victoires des deux français le
comte et butt récit de la journée car
win thin j'en fais des billets sur le
court numéro 1 une silhouette nous
rappelle des souvenirs
et non ce n'est pas bien de borg mais le
yougoslave bruno aurait zar adversaire
d'henri leconte
tous deux s'étaient déjà rencontrés en
88 au deuxième tour également le compte
avait gagné et l'histoire c'est
aujourd'hui répéter malgré une belle
résistance au premier set le miracle n'a
pas lieu pour aurait zar qui n'a jamais
passé plus de deux tours dans un tournoi
du grand chelem
le conte remporte les trois sets 6 4 6 2
6 1 son prochain adversaire le jeune
argentin des vignes qui a éliminé son
compatriote alberto mancini en quatre
sets
andre agassi le chouchou des gamins du
mercredi écoutez plutôt
favori du public l'américain tête de
série numéro 3 a peiné dans le premier
set avant d'imposer sa cadence à
l'australien tom goodridge 136e mondial
éliminé en trois manches
au prochain tour il rencontrera le jeune
français arnaud boetsch issu des
qualifications agassi remercie ses
jeunes supporters apprécient première
fire du lymphatique soviétique andrei
chesnau cov jean philippe flaud rien le
martyrisent dans le premier set 3 041
pour le français son jeu est parfait ces
services meurtrier sa volée précise
éliminer le 2000 finaliste de l'an
dernier le public y croit déjà méch s no
pop sort de sa torpeur et se renvoyaient
infatigable va obliger florian a joué le
tie break après une heure de jeu 8.6
pour le soviétique
il enlève les deux autres sets à la
barbe d'un français démoralisés score
final 7 6 6 2 6 0
chez snopkov rencontrera l'espagnol à
rézé vainqueur du français santoro en
quatre sets
chang 1 m 73 en fond de court face aux
196 cm de marc rosset le suisse 23
centimètres de différence
et pourtant c'est chang qui fait
apprécier sa détente
parce qu'il s'agit d'un trucage
électronique mais les lignes étaient pas
droites et l'on repart en direct pour
roland garros dominique eh oui beaucoup
de rebondissements dans cette partie est
néanmoins et bien c'est yannick noah qui
se trouve maintenant à tous points de la
troisième manche après avoir perdu le
service d'avant ce dont il disposait
depuis le début du troisième set il a
aussitôt récupéré le service de son
adversaire alors qu'il était mené 0 40
c'est dire les rebondissements et la
joie du public de voir de nouveau n'a
mené 5-4 et s'apprêtait à servir dont
peu pour le gain du troisième set
sur cette balle sont maintenant ils
disposent de deux balles pour conclure
après avoir surmonté psychologiquement
un moment extrêmement importante car la
perte de son service aurait pu le faire
flotter le faire du thé et le fait
l'avoir repris dans des circonstances
très difficiles après avoir eu trois
balles de 5 4 contre lui et bien est un
atout qu'il est en train de transformer
c'est peut-être là la balle de deux sets
à un
voilà yali que la mène donc 2 sets à 1 à
partir de 8 m de bureaux
directeur en compagnie de michel brun et
de jean paul loth pour suivre la fin de
cette 1ère ronde
merci dominique est sans doute peu avant
8h50 écourtera le 19/20 pour la bonne
cause pour la vôtre mais les
téléspectateurs ne seront pas privés de
météo pour autant florence il météo très
courts de tennis oblige alors il fera
beau je vous rassure tout de suite c'est
roland garros 2 mais on veut jeter
pardon un coup d'oeil sur notre carte
pour l'ensemble de la france voyait la
perturbation qui passe aujourd'hui
donnera encore quelques nuages sur le
sud-est le matin mais dans l'après midi
les éclaircies seront de retour sur le
nord le nord est et la corse du soleil
avec quelques bancs de nuages ailleurs
du ciel bleu et en fin d'après midi
quelques nuages sur les pyrénées et des
températures d'été fera jusqu'à 26 de
grande bretagne
maintenant sur le sud ouest et 30 au
québec merci florence fin de ce 19 avec
un programme chargé ce soir une soirée
spéciale mélomanes à 20h35 avec le
concours eurovision des jeunes musiciens
à vienne le prochain rendez vous avec
l'information c'est soir 3 à 22h25
présentée par marc hautement et dans
quelques secondes le match à roland
garros avec yannick noah et michel dréan
direct sur l'a3 bonsoir à demain 19h